We have other videos we talk about
about how small molecules or ions
can pass through the cell membrane
in different ways - active, passive
or relieved.
In this video I want to talk
about what's going on with larger objects.
We will focus on
transporting bigger things.
Transport.
In the first example
you can imagine this cell
with the purple membrane swallowing up
this great green thing that can be
bacteria.
You see the membrane -
Let's make things clearer.
It's inside.
This is the inside of the cage.
It's outside.
This is the environment outside the cage.
You can see that the cell membrane starts to
envelops
this bacterium,
finally wrap it completely
and the membrane
is torn off. Now the bacteria
is inside the cage
and is embraced by this layer of membrane.
This process of swallowing large objects
is called phagocytosis.
This is phago -
Phagocytosis.
The prefix "phago"
comes from the Greek word for "eat".
It can literally be translated as a cellular meal.
Very often, this thing here
can be considered as food for the cage.
This compartment keeps
the bacteria to be transported
to the lysozyme, for example, to be processed
and courageous.
We can call this big compartment,
surrounded by a membrane,
food vacuum.
Nutritional.
Food baguette.
This scenario below is similar but slightly different.
Here we have the cage,
we see part of its membrane
in the manga.
We also see the dual phospholipid layer,
that is why I have marked the two-line membranes.
Instead of swallowing a large particle or bacterium,
this cell absorbs some liquid.
Swallows some liquid, you see how it starts
to wrap this part of the liquid,
it embraces it even more,
then the membrane that is around the liquid,
completely detaches and stays in the cage.
I draw all this in two dimensions,
but it happens in three.
This is not just a circle,
but a sphere.
This thing will tear apart
and now it will be inside the cell, we call it a secretory bubble or vesicle.
This is a common term for these cell compartments,
surrounded by a membrane.
This process, in which the cell actually
Drinking different liquids
is called pinocytosis.
Pinocytosis.
A "pino" comes from the Greek word for "drink".
The roots and origin of words have always been very interesting to me.
I'm not an expert in linguistics,
but it's quite interesting to know in other languages ​​I'm familiar with
such as Hund and Urdu,
smoke "pins" means "drink".
It may also be related to the word "panni"
in these languages.
All these words have a common linguistic root,
it's always very interesting to see
such linguistic ties.
So, this is pinocytosis, we can say that to her
the cell drinks and takes up the substances that are contained
in the liquid.
In phagocytosis the cell eats.
These are two specific cases.
We can also use a more general term,
to indicate the swallowing of different objects from the cell,
this is a singlety.
Unicytosis.
Phagocytosis is a type of endocytosis,
pinocytosis is also a type of endocytosis.
Your next question may be,
"Well, I understand that these processes are happening,
can be observed under a microscope,
but how exactly are they going? "
"How does the cell enclose an object and the membrane breaks off?"
In many videos I like to say,
that people think they understand part of a process,
but they do not fully understand it.
There are ideas that the cytoskeleton
plays a role.
You have to make a place here here so he can
the bubble to tear off and move in that direction.
It can also help the cell membrane envelop the object,
but these issues are subject to active research.
How exactly does endocytosis?
How the cage knows what to swallow,
how exactly the membrane behaves,
for the process to take place
successful?